autant la vue est superbe elle autant la
pluie la météo est vraiment peu
dégueulasse aujourd'hui on va laisser
faire un tour de voiture ça retourne
automobile on va essayer la nouvelle
audi du 4e chrono
on avait commandé du beau temps qu'est
ce qui se passe c'est la bretagne
[Musique]
ça va
mais ce temps
[Musique]
oh
donc là j'ai avec mon grand gibier monde
fim motogp il faut qu'on sache que tu
vas assume toi salue la team quand ça va
je vous le dis tout de suite une
présérie c'est pas le modèle que vous
allez acheter vos enfin quasiment les
restes de trois petits trucs et le petit
truc qui reste la partie software qui
est un petit peu de gains avec la caméra
de recul on l'a pas mais ça vous l'aurez
c'est vraiment je suis reconnaissant une
version logicielle qui est pas
définitive et lorsque vous mettez de la
musique parfois le gps sait plus trop où
ils habitent et un truc qui me fait
marrer dans cette voiture c'est qu'en
fait on a déjà le volant qui est plat
sur le haut place sur le bas côté
pratique c'est vous passez vos kilos le
placez vos jambes bien vous avez un peu
plus de place et puis un côté vachement
moderne ça j'aime bien il ya un autre
qui me fait marrer j'ai passé tu as eu
la même idée que moi j b c'est que en
fait tous les intérieurs et les
l'affichage est un peu tourné vingt deux
pilotes s'étaient pas de ta génération
mais moi ça me fait penser à cas de
ville en mode un petit peu moins
prononcée passé k 2000 avait vraiment
l'écran qui étaient là et donc j'ai
vraiment appris à être plus en immersion
maintenant tout que j'aime un petit peu
moins c'est qu'en fait juste en dessous
là bas de la recherche dans l'induction
et que jb et moi on a un iphone 12 prend
max et que chez audi sont dit tiens on
va pouvoir recharger sa passe pas ça ne
s'était pas le contact donc il ya un
côté qu' un peu plus haut un peu plus
bas parce qu'il sait que pour recharger
ben non donc si vous avez un iphone 12
pro mac c'est pas le bon plan sparrow et
l'autre truc qui est un petit peu con
dans l'idée et après j'arrête avec les
défauts c'est que lorsque vous avez
votre téléphone qui renferme l'induction
on a et si vous l'avez pas mis on apple
car place que vous avez apple car play
et qu'en plus vous avez android la boue
tout autour comme à ses cachets par
toute cette partie là qu'est pratique le
seul problème c'est que tu vois pas donc
en termes de sécurité un peu ballot
c'est dire que tu prends ton téléphone
que tu te prennes à la main qui le
regardent pour ciseler mis en appel car
plaît je vois tout ici mais si je n'ai
pas mis baston c'est un peu un peu plus
un peu ça fait un peu râler qu'en terme
de sécu après notre petit rigolo c'est
qu'ici pour monter le son en garde il
n'est pas là tu tournes
du monte le son de grande hauteur on va
faire gaffe tu tournes comme sur un
iphone non tactile
à chaud ça vachement rigolo sinon après
vous avez ici le drive select d'appui tu
choisis dans quel monde tu veux conduire
efficience au dos confort dynamique vous
allez petites palettes au volant donc là
je peux choisir en doses et mon freinage
mon frein moteur en fait c'est juste ici
donc ça c'est assez rigolo voilà ça
freine tout seul en fait je vais rien du
tout et si je relâche la voiture elle
repart légèrement à 7 août des petites
finitions c'est assez marrant est assez
bien vu qu'ils de commandes au volant
après ce que je trouve mais cécile
propres à augy c'est que les petites
touches que vous avez la syrie sur le
volant c'était des trucs qui sont
intuitifs et d'autres non dire que le
volume tu comprends pas ces morceaux
précédents tu comprends ça tu comprends
pas c'est un coup de fil ça tu sais quoi
c'est pour faire apparaître la neige en
fait tu comprends pas trop là tu peux
parler mais peut-être à des gens ne sait
pas trop à qui il ya des trucs là je
trouve que c'est pas hyper intuitif
alors au mieux tu comprends pas ce que
ça te dé gaston écran là tu vois en fait
donc là tu mets foule gps est là sinon
tu mettais tu fais tu vois tu fait
grossir tu comprends tu peux naviguer un
petit peu ici sur la mémoire les trucs
et compagnie ça c'est quoi ça là y'a
rien ça c'est quoi ça ça c'est mon sous
menus de navigation savourer ça le ferme
ça me permet de revenir en arrière je
sais pas quoi là ça me change mon
affichage hockey et ça c'est pour
changer les morceaux et ça c'est quoi en
fait instructions de navigation l'idée
globale et bien d'avoir ces commandes
mais en fait on sait pas réellement à
quoi ça correspond il ya deux trois
trucs qui sont pas hypra est très
intuitif ou alors c'est que moi je suis
pas habitué
[Musique]
soyons clairs c'est la fin du thermique
et odile dit en 2026 le thermique c'est
fini plier emporté ils vont plus en
produire et vont plus en fabriquer ils
vont fabriquer uniquement l'électrique
l'électrique qui vont encore plus loin
et on le voit que cette voiture ici
c'est la audi + 4 itron ça fait beaucoup
de chance dont le nom mais la voiture et
les couleurs déjà le premier truc que
vous voyez c'est un design racé ces duos
dit on aime on n'aime pas mon truc que
je trouve plutôt sympa c'est
qu'effectivement on voit si on a un
sujet qui est qui et musclé call ans qui
est quand même relativement énorme
devant bien plate petit logo audi c'est
solide ces allemands ça c'est beau tout
petit bémol c'est les bornes de recharge
des bars et pas les spéciaux se recharge
sur l'électrique c'est grâce aux bornes
violi ti alors les bornes unity y en a
aujourd'hui 80 en france par bon vous
avez après ça à peu près cinq points de
recharge 80 c'est pas mal vu l'étendue
du parc mais comme le parc va y en avoir
plus en plus y avoir de plus en plus de
bande j'imagine que audi a prévu le truc
forcément mais sur des périodes voyez
comme sept départs en vacances tout le
monde à l'électrique et fait la queue il
nous faut quoi il faut une demi-heure
pour d'allah changer quand même vous
risquez de prendre votre mal en patience
et un peu le aussi un des points
négatifs par rapport au thermique mais
malgré tout ça va dans le sens de
l'histoire or plus vous allez avoir de
nos voitures plus vous allez avoir band
+ réseau va se déployer et ça sera
intéressant lauriad différents modèles
nous c'est le modèle 50 488 km ça va
dépendre de vous ça va dépendre du mode
que vous allez choisir il ya plein de
modes différentes seront plus gagné sur
l'autonomie de te sont plus basés sur la
côte un peu plus sportive autre truc est
très cool c'est les gens vous êtes de 19
à 21 pouces en fonction de la finition
vous allez prendre et cette bagnole elle
envoie du steak vous êtes de 0 à 100 en
6 secondes 2 vous avez
299 chevaux et après la magie opérera
note d'ailleurs
ça souffle tout seul c'est magique bravo
aux 10 h tient à préciser c'est jean
baptiste assez mois moi j'ai tout photos
de tournage vêtements déodorant une nuit
pourquoi tu prends tout ça j y crois tu
t'imposes ça et pourquoi pas et pourquoi
pas il fallait bien montrer qu'il y
avait des raisons les idées de la place
ils pouvaient maintenir encore on pose
un peu plus de sous la taille et vous
avez vous avez des câbles en fait et
donc si vous aimez rangée du câble va
vous pouvez me ranger du câble parce que
ranger du cap s'écouler célèbre vous
monte à un peu plus de 1400 litres quand
vous avez abattu le 6 h moi je sais pas
souvent transforme en utilitaires pour
autant mais si vous voulez une fois de
plus mettre la poussette met jean
baptiste emblée jean baptiste pendant
dix jours en vacances il vous faut les
1400 m
[Musique]
audi vous le savez c'est un constructeur
de voitures thermiques historique fait
ça super bien on est dans le premium
dans l'ultra premium haut niveau de
l'automobile et ça il le maîtrise bien
et là comme tout les marquises opère un
virage pour arriver sur l'électrique on
garde le savoir-faire de dit ici et ça
c'est génial maintenant je te pousser un
petit peu moins génial c'est qu'on voit
qu'on a une très belle voiture y savent
construire des voitures c'est leur
métier ils savent un peu moins faire des
solutions simples et faciles à utiliser
au niveau de l'électronique et c'est un
peu le point un peu négatif est le point
qui a peu en dessous parce le oui
effectivement si moi je viens ici c'est
pas pour vous parler de la motorisation
sont plus là pour venir vous parler de
l'expérience logiciels et reste un petit
peu sur ma faim regardez le truc qu'on
voit déjà c'est pas hyper actif entre le
moment où je bouge mon doigt et moment
ça bouge à l'écran eh ben il ya une
petite seconde et ça ça me dérange un
petit peu c'est donc un petit peu un
petit peu pénible et pour nous mais
désormais il ya une petite expérience où
on se dira il me manque un petit quelque
chose et il me manque vraiment quelque
chose d'extrêmement fluide et c'est un
poil frustrant ce menu là je trouve très
sympa on a des grosses diconne un
véhicule von ah ben c'est pas trop mon
iphone apps et qu'ils n'ont pas mis en
français ok les applications peut-être
c'est ce qu'il fallait venir chercher je
ne sais pas donc médias je vais
retrouver ici ma musique mon téléphone
peut venir passer mes coups de fil mais
contact qui est connecté ici et aju dans
le véhicule éclairage et visibilité
éclairage extérieur éclairage intérieur
fait dans l'éclairage extérieur farah
commande automatique est ce que c'est ça
c'est même pas ça jb bonjour c'est
récupérer un smartphone qui ne rendront
pas sur le pas de rechargement ou ccc ou
là pour régler les phares au départ
ouais je retrouve pas alors monsieur
pour vous réglez vos phares vous avez
besoin d'aller ici dans des îles en
véhicule ensuite vous retrouver dans
éclairage et visibilité puis ensuite
éclairage extérieur et vous voici avec
ici la signature lumineuse numérique
vous pouvez choisir votre signature et
tu vois je retrouvais pas ébats de rien
je suis là pour ça c'est chaud merci je
trouve ça je trouve que ça manque un peu
d'un peu de compréhension en fait tu
vois un tout petit problème wayne et on
s'attend à quelque chose de plus
intuitif et c1 reste avec moi par
exemple a fait quoi sous menus pour
arriver au port ouais ouais ouais c'est
ici manque un petit truc quoi bon mais
c'est que ça risque de logiciels ça peut
changer les cons ça peut se changer
c'est que des logiciels bravo c'est une
belle conclusion monsieur je félicite qu
on a différentes positions de femmes
donc ça c'est assez rigolo ces
définitions pour voir regarder vous
mettez vos phares comme vous voulez et
quand vous changez en fait ça change pas
si vous voulez changer faut confirmer et
c'est pareil petit point de détail quand
j'ai confirmé est ce que c'est vraiment
changé de vent ou pas j'ai un petit clic
que j'aurais peut être aimé un peu
différent pour m'en rendre compte et
c'est une fois de plus un petit point de
détail mais malgré tout c'est pas
extrêmement ça donc je trouve que dans
l'ensemble il ya tout ce qu'il faut mais
il faut vraiment se l'approprier il faut
prendre le temps de venir voir un petit
peu et de comprendre parce que comme ça
c'est vrai que tout de suite on capte
pas tous nécessairement et c'est pas
hyper hyper hyper évident lors de la
recharge regarder en usb c est si je
veux récupérer de l'usb à bas une fois
un petit adaptateur pouvez venir vous
brancher en 12 volts on s'attendait dans
une voiture avec un côté tech à ce qu'on
ait plus de boutons et que tous soient
gérées par un grand écran serait peut
être intéressant d'avoir un espèce de
second écran pour venir gérer ça non ici
ils ont fait le choix de conserver cette
partie là avec des petits boutons alors
ça je trouve ça sympa mais c'est vrai
qu'on n'est pas trop dans un truc tech
on n'est plus dans un usage de véhicule
quelques on le connaissait un petit peu
plus standards tels que le truc qui
serait améliorée dans ces voitures là à
l'avenir c'est de se dire je fais comme
un tesla je me prends un seul et grand
écran et j'optimise toute la partie
software pour qu'elle soit extrêmement
intuitive facile à comprendre mélanger
l'univers de l'automobile mélangez-les
attaque parce que audi en terme de
finition ils sont quand même là les
finitions elles sont magnifiques dans ce
véhicule mais le problème c'est qu'un
vrai déséquilibre entre les finitions le
savoir-faire d'audi qui est extrêmement
maîtrisé au niveau de l'automobile et la
tech qui est un peu en dessous et après
vous avez toute l'expérience audio qui
est signée sonos et l'âge nous met en
mode je le mets pas trop fort
mais si je décide de mettre forte
[Musique]
c'est génial c'est que vous avez quand
même je trouve un son qui est
extrêmement précis et quand on monte le
son on sature pas
c'est du métal déjà saturé mais on sur
sature pas
[Musique]
et merci à vous dis nous avons remis les
prix regarder ces véhicules là si vous
le prenez sans option celui là celui que
j'ai là on est à 67 1950 euros et le
modèle qu'on a ici nous on monte quand
même à 80
5770 euros
ça s'est fait conduire une ode x assez
fun essayer une audi ça s'est fait de
prendre une audi de l'emmener un peu
partout sur deux jours avec et d'aller
visiter autour de saint malo parce qu'on
n'a pas été bien bien ou alors
franchement c'est audi elle est super
sympa elle a plein de points positifs à
la quelques points négatifs la
proposition vous les est cité s'est
effectivement que dans 10 à faire des
voitures ils font très très jolie
voiture et ça on aime bravo audi et
merci aux 10 les pour un petit peu a
retravaillé à mon sens pour audi c'est
toute une partie tech qu'il faut emmener
un peu plus aux voiliers aller plus haut
comme dirait la chanson c'est truc qui
manque un petit peu l'expérience on va
vraiment dubois ya encore qu'il sera pas
aussi sûre cette voiture c'est la
conduite tête haute ça je vous en avais
déjà parlé sur la volkswagen id4 que
j'avais testé que vous avez de la
réalité augmentée lorsque vous conduisez
vous voyez devant vous la vitesse à
laquelle vous voulez la vitesse à
laquelle vous devriez roulait
normalement si ça marche tant mieux
c'est c'est plutôt bien s'est fait un
peu au dessus en fait quand même
relativement attention si vous avez le
gps la navigation ça vous marque quand
est-ce qu'il faut tourner savoir quand
est-ce que vous êtes arrivé c'est
vraiment pratique parce que ça vous
évite d'avoir les yeux sur le compteur
tout en ayant le maximum d'informations
directement personnellement j'aime
beaucoup d'expérience la voiture est
super bien en tant que passager parce
que j'étais beaucoup passagers à côté de
jb ben il me rassure jb je vois bien qui
a l'expérience la maturité de la conduit
donc il me rassure énormément que la
voiture pour ça elle est super super
confort super tenue de route super vécu
un certain budget quand même à 85 0 85
ans qui va mettre 85 millions cette
voiture d'ailleurs peut-être vous
peut-être vous ce que vous avez un petit
budget de 4000 euros sur la voiture
auquel cas ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter voulu marquer en bas bien
évidemment en bas en bas dans les
commentaires sur ce mois je vous
embrasse fait des gros bisous ceux comme
je vais je m'en vais jouer avec ces
partis par là moi je vais partir pas là
je vais nager jeune âge à bientôt salut
ais je sors
je vais nager